we live in a time spent economy things
are competing for
your time and we obviously you can
always get more money but you can't get
more time so time is the finite resource
that we all share
and there's it's the ultimate neutral um
you know
flat leveling leveling playing field
that we all have to operate on
and if you have companies competing for
that you're going to end up with these
problems we're the the resource that is
being strip mined
into our you know our cognition and and
that means that we're worth more if
we're addicted distracted outraged
narcissistic attention-seeking polarized
and disinformed
than if we're a thriving citizen or a
healthy growing child who's
you know living their lives in the way
that we want and i think this speaks to
some of your work andrew because it's
about dignity
it's about are we the product where
we're just a cog in the economy
or do we fundamentally have dignity and
can we have a system that treats each of
us with a kind of sacred dignity
that that it should work that way yeah
it's about do we work for the economy or
does the economy work for us
uh you know are we worth more outrage
than calm it's like well maybe i'd still
prefer to be calm even doing
worth more outraged you know we have to
see to it that we're not all just
instruments of
profit and revenue maximization because
it turns out
maximizing our profitability is really
bad for us
[Music]
good morning and welcome back to yang
speaks this is zach grauman your co-host
of this podcast
look guys i know it's monday we try to
have positive news but i don't have the
best news
we had this dream of doing a crypto
episode for our 100th
yang speaks episode which is very
exciting we had some major technical
issues
um and because of our schedule we were
recording this kind of last minute so
for better for worse we're going to
re-air an episode that i think is
important so tristan harris
is going to be a rerun today and our
regularly scheduled programming
starts back up on thursday we've got the
founder
and ceo of cameo talking about the
future of celebrity
the future of it's been going great if
you guys are still tuning in on
thursdays
and so we will be back i promise
um but we'll never leave you hanging we
got some content coming in tristan
harris episodes awesome
if you haven't heard it if not we're
back to it this thursday
love you guys do me a favor send some
positivity out in the world today
love you guys enjoy tristan harris
re-air
we're back to regularly scheduled
programming on thursday
take care guys
[Music]
it is my pleasure and thrilled to
welcome to yang speaks
someone i consider a friend but more
than that he's a hero of mine in terms
of explaining to folks how technology
uh is hurting us as well as helping us
tristan harris welcome to yang speaks
tristan
andrew thank you so much for having me
it's great to see you again um
i'm gonna keep singing your praises for
a minute tristan i'm gonna keep saying
your praises hi god
design ethicist founder of the center
for humane technology
you might have seen him in what in my
mind was a groundbreaking and
award-winning documentary
uh the social dilemma that's on netflix
one of the most human people on earth
all right sorry i'm going to do your
introduction
justice
[Laughter]
it's really great to be here andrew i've
always tell people hopefully you'll
mention how we met
but um you know it's been just amazing
to see
your really authentic rise from
you know what what i thought were humble
beginnings when we first met at the ted
conference in 2017 and i'm just blown
away by what you've been able to
accomplish
um and anyway we'll get into all of it
but i'm just just as happy to be here
with you
thank you um you and i met
several times uh over the last number of
years
there was ted uh and then there was
an event in new york where arianna
huffington was there
um and uh we reconnected and then there
was a house party
in the bay area where
i was like hey it's just out of the
kitchen like uh
um so it certainly felt like we were
going to
be working together in various ways
and there are so few people who really
there's only one of you
and i want um for people who don't know
you
that well and i know you must be a
little bit tired of relating your
background and how you came to
to this uh this cause this organization
uh but you became kind of a like a
singular
a voice of reason in silicon valley a
number of years ago when you worked at
google
yeah i mean uh so my background for
those who don't know
um i actually just to tell a slightly
different story that i think relates to
your experience i used to be into tech
entrepreneurship um i had a small
startup company
i was ceo of that company was called
apture it was sort of a failure after
five years it got talent acquired by
google
but i i know the startup game i know the
thing that people who are building
engaging
attention-driven applications face when
when you're an entrepreneur and my
friends in college
uh you know i studied computer science
at stanford and was part of a lab called
the stanford persuasive technology lab
i studied there with the founders of
instagram especially mike krieger
who and i who i was project partners
with actually
and we originally were thinking of how
we could apply persuasive technology for
good
which is you know we had this professor
bj fogg who would teach
you know how do we apply the principles
of persuasion to technology and could we
use it to help people live their dreams
live their goals so
work out more floss more whatever it
would be and
um mike and i the founder of instagram
built something called send the sunshine
which was the idea that if you knew two
phones and you knew one of them was in a
zip code
that based on the weather forecast had
five days in a row of bad weather
the other phone was in a good zip code
with good weather it would
send a text message to the person with
good weather to say hey your friend
traston has bad weather you want to send
him some sunshine
so this was using persuasive technology
to orchestrate more
i don't know love or compassion or
kindness for other people
and so we saw those tools but then
overall as things progressed i saw how
more and more of
my really well-intentioned friends got
trapped in this kind of venture capital
driven
viral growth get maximum engagement
maximum time spent
and it become became as the phrase now
is known the race to the bottom of the
brainstem the race into the lizard brain
to try to to get people using their
products and it was through seeing that
and being at google
that i sort of said something's wrong
here and i have to say first
that google was generous and i think
creating a space for me to do some of
that research where i became a design
ethicist thinking about how do you
ethically steer and design people's
attention when you're playing with some
very deep-seated psychological
vulnerabilities
so you mean they didn't exactly hire you
to be a design ethicist
that's right yeah i arrived that through
as sort of the secondary
success of this presentation that was
sounding the alarm about
how we were really kind of like the
stewards the moral stewards of
the human collective consciousness that
two billion people's minds are running
through the kind of wiring diagram of
how we
create the attention economy you know
through our choices like what how does a
notification work how does a news feed
work
how do app store payouts work do you get
paid the more you you
know send you know teenagers to
hospitals for depression or do you get
paid
based on you know subscription revenue
based on people feeling that you're
getting value from something
so all of those mechanics were you know
really part of how
google was positioned to try to be a
federal reserve of the attention economy
or kind of a
government of the attention economy but
the critiques were obviously
much larger than google it was really
about how how does this entire tech
ecosystem
work in the best interests of people
which is why i think it relates very
much to your work like how do we make
this these
systems these economic systems really
work for people
yeah i feel like you and i are tackling
uh related problems
of humanity that we are facing right now
in 2020
i want to rewind a little bit further
back just because i i find you to be
such a fascinating figure you grew up
in um the bay area to a single mom is
that right
yeah yeah um grew up in san francisco
and went to a small
school for for working parents um i grew
up just with my mother not not with
father
and uh then we went and moved up to
santa rosa to the countryside to live
out
her dream of owning horses and um i had
no one in my family was interested in
technology i was the only one who was
always on the computer and learning
programming when i was about 15
and um you know didn't anticipate
anything that would be
happening now certainly so you're the
the geeky kid who's on the computer you
get into stanford which is
not that far away so i'm sure uh you
know you're excited about it
you get there and it sounds like you
were working on technologies to try and
do something positive that
bj fog persuasive technology is uh class
now legendary because it seems like half
of the
major tech entrepreneurs of the the last
generation all went through there
how was your time at stanford and did
people have a sense even then
of uh the magnitude of both the changes
and the companies that would spring from
it
you know when i was there so i was there
from 2002 to 2006
um and you know i should say i was
including with the founders of instagram
and several other of my friends who were
you know really optimistic we used to
meet and wonder like what would be the
ways that we would apply
you know our computer science degrees
towards social impact that's actually we
used to gather every
three weeks or so and sit in some hidden
part of the stanford campus
and brainstorm you know what what those
projects might look like
we supported each other we all had
really positive intentions
you know this is different i didn't know
the people who started facebook although
i remember when facebook
landed on the stanford campus when i was
a sophomore in 2004
and we saw you know the kind of arrival
of photo tagging
and the way that it sort of took over
stanford dorm room life and that's
actually what you see in the film the
social dilemma
is um you know the how the features of
photo tagging which was this perfect
sort of persuasive cocktail
to keep people coming back to facebook
at that time because it's basically
tapping into
you know one of the most ancient kind of
um
uh deep-seated human vulnerabilities
which is social approval hey there's a
photo
it's of you and someone else tagged you
in this photo don't you want to see
obviously if it's a good photo or not
and when they found that that feature
and it worked it's like let's dial that
up like crazy and have everybody
uploading photos and tagging each other
all day
long and i'm sure the productivity of
the entire stanford class dropped by
you know 20 or something like that um
you know
we didn't really know obviously back
then any of this would lead to political
polarization or mental health problems
for kids or you know shred apart you
know the fabric of our
you know information ecology and people
believing in more conspiracies
these came about much later i think
through people realizing where those
incentives of
maximizing engagement and attention
would take us
well you certainly had very positive
intentions because of the nature of the
company you you founded
out of stanford apter and you were
grinding away at that
um so it seems like we may have
something in common where i started a
company
that did not work out i feel like
like your company came a lot closer to
get to working out and that
certainly no one bought my little
company uh to employ us in the way that
google
upon your company so can you tell us a
little bit more about your
entrepreneurial arc with
aptor because as someone who started a
company myself
it was very very hard um it sounds like
you had
some ups and downs too yeah absolutely
and it's funny i don't talk about this
that much
um so app sure just so i explained what
it was um
uh the phrase we came up with it's it's
like lighter fluid for sparks of
curiosity
uh it was a a service that um
when a publisher like the economist or
new york times put it on their website
it would create this ability for a
reader to get on the fly multimedia
explanations about any topic
first started out as a publisher tool so
we had like the climate change blog on
the new york times and
several other sites basically linking
statistics or videos so you would say
hey i want to
so how many of you were there and did
you like uh get a little bit of funding
out of stanford like when you decided to
launch this thing
yeah well i mean i was 22 i think when
we started the company and i actually
was living in argentina learning to
dance tango and on the evenings uh
working
um on this startup from my from a cafe
um
uh but i yeah i mean we we had a few
stanford friends of mine
and senior year uh get together we
raised venture capital
um from um actually we raised angel
investing uh for angel invest
investing money from a couple fathers
and
friends of some other friends of mine
from stanford
and we got our first deal with the
washington post this is back in the
heyday of people
asking what would the future of news and
online context be
uh and the idea was could we do
something really different and radically
new when it came to news online in fact
it was about social impact like for
example could you see
the congressional voting record of every
single politician while you were reading
the new york times and see the video
that they gave
of the speech that they gave on the
house or senate floor um
right there in the article without
leaving the page and we actually built
that so on the washington post for a few
years in 2007 2008
you could click on any congress member
and then see their voting record
and videos of them on the house or
senate floor without even leaving that
article so we were really
trying to create a kind of transparency
and positive social impact and a
reifying of what would make democracy
stronger
of course and this is where the story
turns what what happened
was that publishers like the economist
or new york times or washington post
would ask us okay
we thought we wanted you to help you
know give people these interesting
features to learn about whatever they
want
it ultimately our success metric for
them was did we increase
the amount of time people spend on their
website and that's when it really hit me
that my personal goal which is more of a
social impact almost
aesthetic or art driven goal of can we
make you know democracy stronger give
people better information
was really a different thing than the
business goal which is about
maximizing engagement and attention even
on news websites
and the fact that i couldn't reconcile
that in my own mind that every day
i would kind of tell one story to our
team of engineers we were only about a
10 person company
you know we would tell one story to them
of we're trying to make the world
you know more curious and help people
learn about things but then there'd be
this other
side of it which was measuring our
success on how much time we were getting
people to spend
and i tried to pretend for a long time
that was the same thing
you know just like at facebook like
we're making the world more open and
connected yes we are doing that
but we're also maximizing just
engagement and they seem really aligned
right if one is happening like i'm
making the world more open and connected
then the other things should be
happening people are spending more time
so it's easy to fool yourself into
thinking that they're the same thing
and you know i don't think i've actually
told this this story before but
it was through um a set of other tech
founders and i gathering for something
we call
doubt club that i decided to basically
cave in
and just frankly you know let google
acquire the company for parts
um because you know it was hard to admit
to myself
that really we weren't going to go
anywhere and that this was
this was something that we were going to
be trapped in this attention game
forever
and there would be a limit to the kind
of growth that we could get because we
had to fight for every publisher that
that that used our service on their
website
so we started a group called doubt club
where several founders
realizing that when you're a tech
founder you can't really express
you know that is a very isolating thing
being a founder because you're there
and it's like you're telling your team
hey we we're going around the corner and
tell the investors hey we're going
around the corner
like there's no one but like there's no
founder that's gonna be like hey guys i
actually have my doubts about this
because one of the things that happens
is that any doubt you have gets
amplified and magnified tenfold for
like anyone around you i'll tell you
running for president was like that too
it's like you know
like if the candidate starts up bitching
doubts people will be like
wait a minute i'm dedicating my career
to like trying to get this person
elected what you know so like you have
to be
freaking stoic and on top of it at all
times
completely right i mean and that's
that's the pressure as you're talking
about i mean
in many leadership roles you know
there's no safe place to sort of say
man i'm not sure if this is really the
right path or
maybe this business model isn't maybe we
shouldn't exist even you know
can you even think those thoughts or are
those thoughts unaffordable to you so
this this group was really profound we
we had several friends and the first
rule about doubt club is don't talk
about doubt club because
definitely don't talk about that yeah
many of us we knew each other's
investors and so if you're
grabbing a safe space to talk about
maybe this shouldn't exist
um you know you're not going to go off
and you're going to keep that secret
obviously so
it was through that social support
though that several of us ended up
letting our companies become
talent acquired and what i mean by that
really is acquired for parts i mean this
was not a successful acquisition
and then another person in that group
ended up just shutting down their
organization
and company but again i think what it
really had
us recognize is the internal conflicts
and the kind of denial that we can face
when we're
sitting on top of something you've
raised millions of dollars you've got
12 people working for you've got
livelihoods that depend on you
can you be really honest about when
maybe the thing that got you here isn't
what is really still happening that that
social purpose
and um and that's when you know i think
this started to turn for me and i think
that's what's
at the root of when i look at many
people in the tech industry i don't see
them as evil people i see them as
trapped by a set of incentives that i
think now many of them also
agree are true um and this is just kind
of the place we find ourselves
yeah you experience the incentives
directly on two levels
with aperture number one is uh how does
my
company grow and get paid and that's
related to how
publishers grow and get paid and that's
time spent on their website so they can
sell more advertising
and then the the second set of
incentives is um
if i'm in a leadership role in this
organization then
uh what are my imperatives what am i
allowed to express and not express
and those two things are playing out at
gargantuan almost
unthinkable scale at a place like
facebook because for them instead of
being like hey i'm gonna get an extra
contract from a publisher it's like i'm
gonna get tens of billions of dollars if
we just keep this thing going and then
if you're
a senior executive at facebook you're
like okay i've got the biggest franchise
in the history of the world
um oh some people are telling me maybe i
should examine my practices well let's
see
i have very very powerful incentives
like pulling me this way
and not really that way so you lived it
and i think you understand it more
deeply as a result
well i think that's actually why andrew
i think our our message
um i want to name there's many more
researchers in the community
uh who've been studying some of these
problems whether it's doug rushkoff or
sophia nobel
or others who focus on different aspects
of these harms
and we're really build on building on
the work of those people but i think the
reason that
when when our message came around that
it really resonated with people
inside the tech industry is it spoken in
the vocabulary and language that they
actually operate in which is
do you have a metrics dashboard do you
measure daus daily active users do you
use
do you measure maus do you measure
engagement time time spent
um seven day actives we know the common
metrics and design decisions and the
kind of vocabulary
that people on the inside use so i think
when we spoke
it was the first time that i think
people on the inside had to come to
terms with
the fundamental misalignment of
incentives that i think people didn't
want to look at and i just want to name
that because
you know while i think we've been
successful at that we're building much
on the insights of people who came
before and have been creating these
these areas whether it's sherry turkle
or
you know more recently uh jean tuenge
and jonathan height there's there's lots
of great people who are doing the
research and they're also in the film
um but uh i think we've been successful
because we've been speaking a language
that makes it more universally
understood
for for the masses and that's why the
film actually is so exciting because i
think
having it received in 190 countries and
in 30 languages
you know being number one in india
number one in lebanon recently
breaking records on for documentaries on
netflix i think it's created a
cultural moment a global cultural
awakening
um akin to something like inconvenient
truth or a silent spring but for the
toxic business models of
uh some of the tech companies it's so
important i am so
uh proud of you and whoever
uh busted their tails trying to get that
movie into the world and netflix for
taking it up and distributing it thank
you netflix
all right if you've been listening to
the show for a while you've heard us
rave about our helix mattresses
because they're awesome so helix
mattress has left the bedroom and
started making sofas and they started a
company called
all form and they're making freaking
fantastic sofas i have one in my
apartment
it's light gray it's three seats wide
it's got a little foot thingy
and it's freaking amazing what makes
this thing so freaking cool it is so
easy to customize a sofa
without like compromising quality right
so you can pick your fabric
you can pick your color you pick the
color of the legs your size whether you
want the
massive sectional you want the little
ottoman little leg thingy you can do it
all
they've got arm chairs i love seats all
the way to eight-seat sectionals so it's
massive and they're delivered to your
home like the mattress and you can
assemble it yourself
i'm an idiot and i assembled my couch
and it feels like it's built like a rock
you get a hundred days to decide whether
or not you want to keep it which is more
than three months and if you don't love
it they pick it up for free
and give you full refund so here's the
deal
find your perfect sofa check out all
form.com
yang and all form right now is offering
20
off all orders for our listeners at
allform.com
yang so check it out we love all form
[Applause]
so so you have this tough uh series of
meetings at doubt club and you say look
i think capture is not going to
uh to stand the test of time or grow the
way i wanted to
um so then to get yourself aqua hired
for parts
uh by google is that like an easy thing
because you know
you're a hyper talented guy i'm sure
some of your engineers are hyper talent
does it like
pick up the phone do you have video
friends at google we were like hey like
let's get this conversation going how
does that work
yeah it's an interesting um question um
i didn't i had some friends who were at
google but i didn't know any of the
leadership there
um certainly i think we were you know
what it was actually i could tell you
the story
um there was you remember when cora
first launched
yeah yeah and so adam deangelo who is
the cto of quora
had um started this question and answer
site which everybody now knows is called
cora
and there is the early community of
quora adopters and
one of the first questions that i think
i think it was zuckerberg who asked the
question on quora and it said who are
the most
sorry i'm not trying to toot my own horn
here i'm just trying to please go ahead
but um zuckerberg had posted who's the
what are the most talented companies and
people that in silicon valley right now
that most people don't appreciate
and there's obviously lots of you know
questions and sorry lots of answers to
that post
but the one that people voted up the
most was actually apture um
and and our team and so i think that
post where we were
highlighted as a uniquely talented group
of people
led to some conversations about
acquisitions with google i came
to know sundar pichai who at the time
was he's obviously now ceo of google but
at the time he was
head of chrome and apps and you know we
started an acquisition process with
a small competition it was very
challenging i mean actually you know
these things take a long time and it was
uh
really one of the most stressful and
depressing periods of my life to be
honest because
you have to admit that you know you've
been working for six years incredibly
hard and it's all just
you know you're gonna we got eaten up by
the borg i mean our entire service and
all the publishers and all the code and
all the data and everything we had done
got you know you know became became ash
uh
once we got acquired but um i think it
did teach me some many valuable lessons
and i think it created the foundation
for the design ethics work that that
took us to
now so you get absorbed by google they
put you on which team uh
was it um gmail yeah they put us
on the chrome and apps team which then
so we started working on
some advanced like personal assistant
type work
um and then that led to working with the
gmail team
uh and i started looking at i was
working with the people who were
designing the next version of gmail
and you know i found myself in the room
with
you know the designers who manage this
interface where people i mean you go to
any internet cafe
back before covid and you see almost
every laptop has this like gmail
page open right i mean almost everywhere
oh yeah we all know it sure we all know
like
people live in this space it's a habitat
it's not just a product we use it's a
space we
we live and we work in and given that
importance i thought to myself you know
um as we're designing the next version
of this this is an opportunity
to really think about how this is an
enormous source of stress in people's
lives you know
it's funny because i think one of the
responses to the film when i say
in the film that i'm really addicted to
my email a lot of people don't
understand that because email's sort of
just junk mail for for a lot of people
but coming from
i think the the generation that you came
from and that i came from email
is a central place where especially at
the time every now and then i would be
getting um
you know big introductions to people who
would help us advance the work
so it became my own slot machine to
check you know is did daniel kahneman
the head of you know the founder of
behavioral economics email me and
that kind of thing but that said we know
i was thinking about
uh is gmail really good for people
i was thinking about you know this is a
pretty addictive stressful
place in people's lives could we reduce
social expectations could you make it so
that when you send an email you could
say
hey i actually don't need a response for
two weeks could we start to implement
features that would reduce the
addictiveness
and you know there i am in the room and
there's no other room in the world
besides that gmail design team room and
if
that was the room the room where it
happened and i thought if there was any
room where people would care about this
this would be the one and i found to no
disparagement of my colleagues who were
working at the time
i just didn't find the conversation
really
as thoughtful as it needed to be given
the consequences that we were having for
like six hours or four hours of people's
days
so first how many people were in that
room
good question i think probably somewhere
between six to ten people
usually in those rooms okay how long
were you at google before
uh the this uh this discussion is
happening
um so within about three months we had
joined the gmail team and we're starting
to have those conversations so pretty
three to four months i was in there and
then
you sent out a now legendary deck around
hey we should probably be thinking more
deeply about the
choices we're making because they're
about to influence billions of people
over time uh what was was that um
just months after you joined google yeah
that was in
january of uh one year in so basically
one year into being at google after
trying to make it work with the gmail
team you know i really did i really
wanted to see us ship something that
would make a dramatic positive impact in
people's mental health around email and
stress and
notifications and attention and um
because it wasn't going anywhere and
because overall
like other apps whether it was quora or
path or all the you know instagram at
the time which was just you know blowing
up
um i was just disappointed in where are
we as a tech industry heading like what
where have we lost our moral compass do
we really care
about what we're building and how it's
impacting people or have we kind of
forgotten um you know that there's more
to just capturing lots of attention and
going getting virality
and so i i started um i went on a trip
to the santa cruz mountains with my um
one of my best friends aza raskin who
his father jeff raskin invented the
macintosh project at apple
and that's where we get our name in
humane for the center for humane
technology
asa's father jeff wrote a classic book
called the humane interface which is the
foundation of some of our work
but aza and i were in the santa cruz
mountains and
you know connecting with nature and just
being out there and it just really
struck me that
i needed to go back and there needed to
be something that was said about this
and it the words came to me and that
trip and it was never before in history
have a handful of technology designers
who mostly look like
you know hipster engineers in san
francisco between 25 35 years old
mostly men mostly white um you know
making decisions on behalf
of a billion people was the number of
the time now it's three billion people
to show you the growth rate of how fast
these things go and
the presentation included just a bunch
of examples you can actually find it
online on
minimizeddistraction.com i think is
where someone had leaked it and posted
it
but it used a bunch of examples of how
technology's
tapping into our psychological
vulnerabilities
and the cost that it was having on kids
on mental health
and it ended up going viral i sent it to
a few people
for feedback and instead of the 10
people i sent it to exclusively
i came to work the next day and i had
like 100 emails about it
so i knew it had gone viral to many more
people and
as the film the social dilemma says you
know it went up to larry page's office
in several different meetings that day
and i think it created a moment of
reckoning where we actually said hey can
we do something about this and i would
host follow-on lunches at google
bringing people together from different
teams to talk about it but it was just
hard to get
a real coordinated action because the
external global pressure from consumers
or from the world or from governments
just wasn't there and that's what's
astonishing is to see where it is now
because compared to
you know lunchroom meetings that i would
book at a random part of the google
campus with
you know 12 people showing up saying how
do we fix this
uh to today where you have i think
something like 30 to 40 million people
are going to have seen this film very
soon
in 190 countries it feels like it's
taken eight years to get to a point
where we're gonna be able to
meaningfully change these incentives
so this is 2012 that you uh
send this deck out and then it goes
viral like google yeah
2012 to 2013 somewhere around there
beginning end of 2012 early 2013.
all right let's call it uh early 2013
then um
so when you send this deck out to your
10 contacts
um were you concerned at all that this
is going to make you seem like
uh someone who is not on board with like
the
like the general direction of uh
development of uh the project you're on
i mean you're relatively new to the
company it's an enormous company
um and the rest of it like is there any
concern that is gonna be bad for your
career
yeah um i'm glad you're bringing this up
because it's easy to skim past this now
i was i actually had no idea how people
were gonna respond i was prepared that
if i had gotten fired for some reason
because of it that i would be okay with
that so i had pre-committed that that
was an okay thing
an okay outcome for me um and
i was you know i was actually really
afraid
to send it out which is why it was
surprised me when so many people
when it shared virally i mean you know
on google slides you can click
on a presentation it shows you in the
top right hand corner how many
simultaneous
viewers there are and there was
something like 150 and then later that
day like 400 simultaneous viewers
you know in a 10 000 you know whatever
it was 20 000 person company back then
so uh i did not
expect to be i've never been in my life
a person who went against the grain who
was highly disagreeable who was trying
to challenge things i wasn't outspoken
it just struck me that no one was
sufficiently paying attention to this
and it was too important not to um
so then it sounds like the feedback was
by and large quite positive so much so
that they actually give you this new
title and role saying you're going to be
our
our new design ethicist you're going to
tell us what's what
um so how how was that transition and
role and how long were you in that role
yeah so this is important i there was a
fellow at the
google creative lab in new york who had
actually helped co-write to make this
the story all circular he helped
co-write the first macintosh
uh the famous macintosh super bowl ad if
you remember the woman
running down the streets and throwing
the hammer and smashing the big
brother's screen
he had co-written that advertisement um
and uh he had seen this presentation at
google
and was really impressed by it we
connected on um
uh this this book that had really shaped
him by neil postman called amusing
ourselves to death
uh which is really i think entirely
descriptive
of exactly everything that's going wrong
right now that
culture and our society would surrender
to the forces of technology
and technology would become would start
to subsume
culture and remake culture in its image
and that we would be caught in this kind
of race not for attention didn't express
it that way
but this race to make things amenable to
how technology would want to see and
shape the world metrics like
you know in this case he was talking
about sat scores and predictive
analytics for college admissions and
things like that
but he didn't at the time know about a
few years later we'd have tech companies
running by the metrics of
time spent and engagement and that book
i'm using ourselves to death
opens with this description that we were
all watching out for the year 1984
when the form of dystopia and tyranny in
the form of big brother
and the orwellian vision of dystopia
would would come to you know subsume
society and then luckily it didn't come
to pass we
made it through 1984 and that didn't
happen but he says that there was always
this second vision of dystopia
that was the more subtle one that people
don't remember as much which is aldous
huxley's brave new world
where the tyranny is not of restricting
access to information or censoring what
you can or can't think
but instead bludgeoning people with a
sea of irrelevance
with so much narcissism and egoism and
passivity and informational
overwhelm that people wouldn't know
what's true and they'd be amusing
themselves to death and this was the
book
that this fellow at google who offered
to host me
to work on this problem and i connected
on and then i started to become
i didn't know what to call it so we just
said let's call it design ethics
and no one had ever thought how do you
ethically design
along the social psychological
vulnerabilities of humanity
and it became more of a research project
for the first
two years and i tried changing various
things within google we tried talking to
the android team and changing things on
chrome and
how would we make smartphones work
differently and talk to the app store
teams about changing incentives
but um i couldn't get anywhere and so
about three years
later um i decided to leave and
soon after that i was on the sam harris
podcast where um
you and i i think both launched our
careers in a certain sense
and sam harris thank you
[Laughter]
that podcast was the kind of coming out
moment for this work
and chris anderson who runs ted emailed
me
a few days later which was i think only
three days before the ted conference
and said i need to get you to come to
ted to do a ted talk on what you just
shared on sam's podcast and um i was
actually about to fly to czech republic
with
my mother who was dying at the time and
this was the last time that we were
going to take a trip
abroad and i decided to go but then cut
my trip short
go to ted had two days to prepare this
first ted talk on how technology
controls a billion minds
and that's where i met you um and i
remember the moment it happened at the
you know the buffet table i think on
that friday um and
um yeah that was that's a long time ago
now
well i i did not know what the run-up
was too
you know for me i was just blown away by
your talk and was like this that was
incredible
that's like um so hearing like i didn't
know about sam
and um certainly not um
uh you know you're abbreviating your
trip with your mom
all right you know what an
out-of-the-box idea for mother's day is
a hello tushy bidet yes hello tushy is
still a sponsor of yang speaks and the
bidets are still
awesome it's a great idea for mother's
day because they're stylish they're
eco-friendly
they're easy to install they feel great
they cut down on toilet paper cross and
they help the environment so hello tushy
3.0
is the champ it cleans itself it's got
this smart spray
automatic self-cleansing nozzle is super
easy to attach
it cuts your toilet paper used by 80
guys toilet paper adds up
and look every hello tushy bidet
attachment comes with a 60-day risk-free
guarantee and a 12-month
warranty so get the hello tushy 3.0
bidet give the gift of a clean butt go
to hellotushy.com and get 10
off plus free shipping pretty cool 10
off free shipping that's a special order
for yang speaks listeners at
hellotushy.com
slash yang for 10 off so it's
hellotushy.com
yang
[Music]
[Applause]
so when you decide to leave google
here's the thing google
famous for its food famous for all this
stuff you're hanging out there
you've got this design ethicist job and
you're like hey android try and do
something better hey
you know like everyone trying to do
something better and you realize you're
not making headway
i still feel like 99 of people would
have been like
just stay there forever do your thing
because you're in like corporate womb
like you know people
respect you uh you're still in the
mothership
um so it feels like a big decision to be
like all right this is not working it's
time for me to go particularly when
when you decided to leave um it didn't
seem like it was clear what the next
steps would be
you know it's so interesting andrew i
really appreciate you asking these
questions uh uh
it that's exactly right it did not at
all feel clear
you know leave and go do what like how
you're inside of the biggest
most influential company in the world um
that is probably one of the biggest
surface areas for
these problems showing up which is all
of android which actually has a majority
of smartphone users around the world in
the us
obviously it's more iphone skewed um why
in the world would you leave
that environment and obviously be paid i
think nicholas nassim telep
wrote the line that the three most
addictive things in the world are
cocaine
heroin and a monthly paycheck it's very
hard to walk away from
you know monthly security job security
and i really didn't know how we would
ever change
um these problems i i remember
feeling deep anxiety about what it would
mean to leave and not
and live off my savings frankly and
figure out what how in the world what do
you do to sort of get
people to care about something in a
public stage
and there was about a year and a half
after that
where nothing happened and it was when
i think trump got elected and the
election took place and the conversation
started happening about
russian manipulation of the elections
and i had seen
certain things like this myself and had
been part of a community of researchers
who'd been tracking
some of those manipulations that i
decided i had to jump in full steam
into um into this problem even if i
didn't know how we would
i would get the you know get the
attention it deserved and the real brick
breakthrough there was the 60 minutes
piece
in um 2017 called the addiction code
with anderson cooper
and that was the first um i think major
event where
insiders from the tech industry were
speaking out about it and that's what
led to sam harris and that's what
i think helped accelerate this
conversation it was roger mcnamee who
wrote the book zuckt
and i did an interview he was actually
the the person on bloomberg
hosting if you don't know roger mcnamee
wrote the book sucked he was
an early investor roger is
uh very very smart and i i admired that
book and his work
yeah and and he was an early mentor to
mark zuckerberg in the early days he
actually was brought in as the opening
chapter of the book zucked says to sort
of convince mark not to sell the company
to
i think it was microsoft or yahoo and to
instead
that he had one of the biggest companies
in the world on his hands and so
anyway so roger felt very similarly but
he was sitting there on the sidelines
and hosting this show on bloomberg tv
and after 60 minutes i went on the show
and he called me afterwards and said do
you need a wingman
and we set out to try to figure out how
do we start this conversation and we
were at ted together trying to figure
out
could we build allies and honestly we
had almost no one listening or paying
attention uh people were not
really engaged and it's taken just so
long to get the kind of public
conversation to to to match it now
yeah they're paying attention now so so
there's sam harris
ted um i feel like there was a steady
drum beat
of news and awareness jaren lanier is
part of this i believe
absolutely um uh
but i will say that when you sent me a
message saying hey great news netflix
documentary social dilemma
like it was still like a pretty big um
surprise to me and i know these movies
take a while
so so how the heck did the resources
behind the social dilemma
uh come about i feel like there must be
some heroic filmmaker we owe a debt to
absolutely so i just want to say also i
was just a you know primary subject in
the film
um we didn't produce the film i'm not
making money from the film a lot of
people think
you know they accused us of i don't even
know trying to make money off of talking
about the problem and this couldn't be
farther from the truth
um uh but we
so so the film was in the works for
about three years starting in 2017 in
fact
many of the interviews that are of that
i'm in that that i there of me in the
film
were recorded in early 2018 late 2017 i
think
so um you know and they bear relevance
to to now and i think it speaks to just
how consistently
these issues were going to appear in
society the filmmaker jeff warlowski
was actually at stanford during the same
years that i was there we were both
apple campus representatives believe it
or not and
he had made two award-winning climate
change films one called chasing ice
and another called chasing coral about
you know the disappearance of coral and
and
you know the glaciers up in the northern
parts of the world
and we saw this as kind of a climate
change of culture
piece uh he didn't really know about
these problems he'd been following
um you know some of my work having
risen up in 2017 and we started talking
about it we had met the producers
laurie david and heather reisman who we
owe just incredible gratitude to through
actually through ariana huffington so
who we also owe incredible gratitude to
and this film got off the ground um and
it took
like we said about three years for it to
come out till now
and you know it was really important for
us to have it come out before this
election because i think it's
possibly most consequential for our
democracy we talk about a lot of harms
mental health of kids
talk about addiction but i really think
it's the breakdown of our shared
information ecology
and our ability to trust in shared
sources of information
and to walk away from you know a debate
and see the same movie as opposed to
different movies
i think this is the most existential
aspect that the film
really gets at is our our shared reality
is being torn apart like a paper
shredder
into three billion narrower and narrower
uh auto program truman shows where they
are programmed to give us a more
affirmation that you're right the other
side is wrong and here's even more
evidence
of whatever you believe about
controversial polarizing topics
and when you do that and you you run
that psychology opt you know
i think of like an optometrist who puts
this pair of glasses on your eyes
and they put those glasses on us 10
years ago because we started looking out
through the glasses of facebook
to see what is the world what's really
going on out there and we've been
wearing these instead of far sided or
near-sighted glasses we've been wearing
these outrage sided glasses
for about 10 years now and again not
just facebook but
but the kind of twitter you know outrage
machine the youtube outrage machine
and so we're 10 years into this deep
psychology experiment
that has become the new normal and we
don't so it's not just about let's fix
the platforms now let's also what i hope
the film does
is kind of rewind the clock and say if
imagine if you wore
this hypothetical outrage colored
glasses so you walk into your kitchen
and wherever you look it shows you
something you could be outraged at like
your spouse
left the dishes in my freaking coffee
my coffee can my coffee can wasn't there
exactly your coffee can is not there and
it's not even in the place you usually
leave it the dishes are out it shows you
who left the dishes out
when you look on the refrigerator handle
you see that someone sneezed on it
because it
the glasses highlight the green you know
micro particles of germs or something
so imagine you were wearing outrage
colored glasses everywhere you looked
and imagine you were wearing those
glasses for 10 years how would you
feel and think and act and navigate in
the world
if that was the construction and basis
of your reality and that's exactly what
we've had with
i think these social media platforms
again no one at twitter
we both know jack you know i think
intended for any of this to happen
it's just that this became this business
model and once the companies go public
they're they're forced to be on this
treadmill of keeping growth going and
growth is directly connected to
time spent and engagement yeah jared
lanier when we talked he said well we
looked up and said
seems like advertising is like the best
uh best business model we could think of
but then
taken to a multi-billion dollar extreme
it ends up having
um very the negative incentives attached
because
it's like okay now i gotta gin up
engagement and how am i gonna jit up
engagement
by making you outraged at something or
afraid
or um eager to blame someone else
uh so i agree with the your description
of the problem the magnitude of it um
simultaneously to the this run-up
between 17 and
uh 2020 you also co-founded organization
center for humane technology that's
trying to
make people more mindful uh can you talk
a little bit about what the the center's
goals are yeah um so the center for you
and there's also time well spent you
which i don't know which one you want to
want to
go into well yeah so the original work
was
um under the spotlight of a of an
advocacy group called time well spent
and the idea behind this was from the
continuity of the first ted talk that i
that i gave in 2013 or something like
that
which was about the idea that we live in
a time spent economy that things are
competing for
your time and we obviously you can
always get more money but you can't get
more time so time is the finite resource
that we all share
and there's it's the ultimate neutral um
you know flat
leveling leveling playing field that we
all have to operate on
and if you have companies competing for
that you're going to end up with these
problems and we said the answer is
imagine a world where technology
competes to help us spend time well
and they're competing on the on the
basis of that finite resource
to direct it in the places that we would
say align with our own values
that work was important and became you
know the first stage of this
of all of this but it didn't capture the
the vast like polarizing conspiracy
theories
other kinds of effects that were really
at the heart of this and we needed a new
instantiation and frankly a real funded
non-profit vehicle to do this work
so roger mcnamee randy fernando
andy sorry asa raskin my co-founder
co-founders of the center for humane
technology
put together this group and we actually
partnered with common sense media at the
beginning
and common sense media for those who
don't know is an advocacy organization
who focuses
on the issues of kids in screen time and
privacy related issues
and we really partnered up to do
advocacy in california
state legislature we did a conference in
dc called the truth about tech
conference
and we've done a bunch of media and
started making noise about these
problems
and since then you know the center is
really focused on realigning
technology's incentives with humanity's
best interests
um simply put because the the
fundamental incentives of
these large dominant platforms are
directly profiting
from conspiracy theories polarization
breakdown of mental health the more
addicted your kids are the more anxious
they are
not that again anyone wants this to
happen the line in the film that i think
describes it best that justin rosenstein
says who invented the like button is so
long as a whale
is worth more dead than alive and a tree
is worth more as lumber than as a tree
and we don't regulate
private forests or protect you know
state state forests
now we're the whale we're the tree we're
the the resource that is being strip
mined into our
you know our cognition and and that
means that we're worth more
if we're addicted distracted outraged
narcissistic attention-seeking polarized
and disinformed
than if we're a thriving citizen or a
healthy growing child who's
you know living their lives in the way
that we want and i think this speaks to
some of your work andrew because it's
about dignity it's about are we the
product
where we're just a cog in the economy or
do we fundamentally have dignity
and can we have a system that treats
each of us with a kind of sacred dignity
that that it should work that way yeah
it's about do we work for the economy or
does the economy work for us
you know are we worth more outrage than
calm it's like well maybe i'd still
prefer to be calm even
above worth more uh outraged you know we
have to
see to it that we're not all just
instruments of
uh profit and revenue maximization
because it turns out
maximizing our profitability is really
bad for us
it means that we're we're very very
pissed off and ready to
click and act and watch whatever videos
you want to serve to us at any moment in
time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right you know what time it is here
on yang speaks we are always sponsored
by athletic greens
i freaking love athletic greens i use it
all the time every day
wake up open the blue pouch pour this
green powder into half a glass of water
mix it up and drink it and it's
wonderful
it makes me feel better i don't eat that
well in the pandemic
and this makes me feel like i'm covering
all my bases and that's because one
scoop
of athletic greens which taste great
contain 75 vitamins minerals
whole food source ingredients including
a multivitamin multi-mineral probiotic
green superfood blend and more they all
work together to fill nutritional gaps
in your diet
increase your energy and focus which it
does it does increase your energy and
focus a bit
and aids with digestion and supports a
healthy immune system all
without the need to take multiple
products so here's the deal visit
athleticgreens.com yang and join health
experts athletes and health conscious
go-getters around the world
who make a daily commitment to their
health every day simply visit
athleticgreens.com yang get your free
year supply vitamin d and five free
travel packs today with your first
purchase
that is our deal for you five free
travel packs and a free year supply of
vitamin d
at athleticgreens.com
[Music]
it's great to give people this sense of
what it took to get to this moment
the social dilemma the fact that now in
large part because of you
individually and all the people that
have helped
you and your work that the awareness
about the nature of these problems is
now higher than it's ever been
and if you look at polling around big
tech big tech has gone from can do no
wrong
to whoa like there are some real
problems and excesses that we're going
to have to figure out and get to the
bottom of
you can see that with the recent
anti-trust hearings and the rest of it
which is one angle
um to me that's like fine um
but it's missing some of the fundamental
problems it's like you know
like pretending these tech companies are
you know oil companies or steel
companies whatever it's like not really
doing the trick
um so this is the the big um
the big thing i want to pick your brain
on so i'm so full disclosure
because this might entertain you people
would i would say things on the trail
like hey uh
quoting you i sometimes i attributed
sometimes i did and i knew you wouldn't
care
but i would say we have some of the
smartest engineers in the country
turning super computers into dopamine
delivery devices for
our kids and it's having a disastrous
effect on our mental health
teenage girls in particular according to
jonathan hayden and eugene twenge's data
and then every parent in iowa new
hampshire
who heard this were like yeah because
they see their kids getting
addicted to their screens and you know
it's not great for their development
and then they would turn to me and say
what are we going to do about it and
then i would say you know what we're
going to do
and here's where i don't know if you
said this i said
as your president i'm going to start at
the pension detent uh department of the
attention economy
and i'm going to have my friend tristan
harris run it
tristan has been been trying to change
the design decisions of these tech
companies for years
now most of them you know just gave like
uh oh like you know andrew
knows someone specifically who who has
the right thinking about this
but uh if we were to play that scenario
out
what do we need to do to try and
uh humanize our technology and our use
of it
first i just want to say a few things to
what you shared um
man yeah well i just want to say i i
appreciate it so much that you
like with universal basic income and
like with other aspects of your platform
you i think have always prioritized a
kind of public education
in your work in trying to help people
understand and elevate issues that are
not being talked about and using your
presidential campaign to do that i think
that
was amazing you did that with ubi and
you've also been doing that with the
attention economy and
um you know i think you helped make it
even a bigger issue and i
just really want to say i really
appreciated that that you you led the
way
uh on elevating it as as i think to its
rightful position is one of the top
issues facing society because it's
underneath and exacerbating
all the other issues it makes it
impossible to solve any problems if we
can't even agree on reality
exactly exactly and that's what we say
in the film so clearly is if we can't
agree on reality we can't solve any
problem whether it's climate change
poverty or social justice and racism or
whatever we want to we want to deal with
so truth be told this is not an easy
thing
to regulate um it has to do with core
business models i do think we can look
to ways that the climate movement thinks
about
an increasing overtime tax
um to carbon you know to carbon
externality setting a price on carbon
you know so essentially
as we've talked about um this is an
extractive economy where instead of
extracting oil out of the ground and
then
producing you know climate change at a
global level in the commons depleting
the environmental commons and
also eroding the the life support
systems of the planet that's the
fossil fuel economy in this case we have
an extractive economy
built on not just extracting human
attention but as we talked about in an
earlier interview we did
fracking for human attention because
we're worth more also when we're
multitasking
it's really quickly on that we're worth
more when you have a tablet a phone and
your television up and that triples the
size of the attention economy because
now you're paying attention to three
things
so so dark
but one one thing that very much like
that when you use the metaphor of
fracking for attention you start to see
that we're selling just like the
financial crisis
thinner and thinner slices of human
attention
as if it's worth the same as valuable
concentrated attention but it's kind of
junk attention just like
we're selling thinner and thinner credit
default swap type you know
junk instruments financial instruments
and selling it as if it's this bigger
thing
and propping up this kind of inflated
advertising attention market
so i think one one thing we can do is we
can correct for that inflation
um and i think there's one study from a
couple years ago where facebook was
found to inflate
the amount of advertising reporting that
it did for
um their advertisers by 900 meaning they
exaggerated how much
um the viewership or clicks there was by
900 percent
so that's just like you know a financial
broker exaggerating the value of
you know a financial instrument by a lot
so we can kind of
clean up comprehensively this
systemically fragile
fragility creating system so much like
you wanna
you can't just say we're gonna get
completely off of oil in one year and
carbon
prices are gonna be set to a million
dollars a ton and
we're gonna move over you set up a
transition plan over 10 years
so i think what we need is a transition
plan from each company
maximizing how much attention that they
kind of extract
to winding down how much commodification
of human attention that we can do over
time
one model of this actually comes from
the way that we regulate energy
companies because it used to be that pg
e or con edison or whatever your energy
company is they're a
for-profit company theoretically they
want you to use as much energy as
possible so
leave the lights on leave the faucets on
maximize your just wasting of
energy and you're maximizing climate
pollution you know
activity and behavior they can even put
those nests in your home and then
maximize how much you use to like
manipulate you into using the most
that would be a kind of dystopian
reality our our recommended home
temperature
is 95 degrees
and get you to change it all the time
and you know anyway
so obviously that would be an extractive
kind of business
and it's fundamentally misaligned with
the commons because it accelerates
climate change et cetera
so we've dealt with this problem before
we actually have regulated utilities
that set seasonal targets for how much
money you can make
as a utility off of a certain amount of
energy so for example
if there's a seasonal availability of so
much energy it costs this much for this
lower tier usage and then if you're a
consumer and you use let's say beyond
that amount
because it's a hot summer they actually
double charge you for that next phase of
of energy that you're using except those
extra profits don't go into the the
coffers of pg e or con edison
they go into a public fund uh that
actually re
invests in the renewable energy
infrastructure that we need
so that's a nice i don't know if you
want to it's sort of a nice transition
plan of
oh like oh i caught that i don't
know how i explained this to you about
you probably know these things better
than i do frankly but no no no no so
so let me let me just try and walk
through this just for fun so let's say
um you and i are getting together and
we're part of the department of
detention economy and we're like all
right
hey facebook here's the deal um
we we find you um excessively extractive
in terms of the amount of attention
you're getting from folks so
step number one stop exaggerating the
amount of time we actually spend on you
that's that's number one but number two
um for every bit of attention you get
beyond a certain period let's call it
like our uh four plus four
uh teenager like there's actually like
some negative social value associated
with that um
so we're going to have you
pay a penalty um and then use that
penalty then to fund
some alternatives let's call it like
little leagues
or whatever like we bought something
that
that would be like the anti um
facebook um uh type of counter measure
uh is that more or less accurate
well i also want to say this is a tiny
part of a probably a more comprehensive
way of dealing with these problems but i
think
um there's an there's a part of it which
is that we have to remove some of the
perverse
um incentives um yeah what you're saying
now
reminds me of something i said when i
went to the can
con whatever you say uh call it uh
pronounce it uh advertising festival
where um you know we were talking to the
advertisers that fund all this activity
and these mental health harms
and said um you know after there's a
mental health crisis from kids
and there's a loneliness crisis
someone's gonna ask the question who
paid for all of this to happen
and it's obviously these advertisers and
one of the things we proposed was
imagine you just simply cannot make
money from usage
between let's say midnight and six in
the morning if you're a tech company
that disincentivizes usage of um sort of
late night lonely use that's sort of the
low willpower period
of of use now that's that's definitely i
don't know what you're talking about
tristan i have never
done any low willpower ted tech uh
social media use between those hours
i think uh yeah i think you you are the
superhuman willpower uh one among us
kidding we've all done it but it's but i
love that idea so much where you cordon
off
a number of hours where you're like look
extracting attention in these hours is
not not a good thing
it's like treating a park you know those
trees some of the trees we extract and
we turn into lumber other trees we say
this is part of a national park and
they're for walking and exploring and
enjoying
right and it's like some of our
attention can be maybe
you know part of a system that obviously
wants to commoditize it but that's
another thing is there's sort of a
violation
of turning a live humanness and a live
human choice
into these dead slabs of human behavior
through behavior modification engines
right so we turn like a live
consciousness
into this sort of deadened consciousness
in which your behavior is more or less
predictable because we've
taken what could be a free choice and
turn it into an unconscious habit
which is a form of kind of like dead
lumber as to a tree what dead
you know human behavior is to a live
human being there's many different
aspects to this that i think we have to
correct i think what we need here is
overall something more
comprehensive just like with the
financial crisis if you asked me andrew
and said what's the
one law that we passed that's going to
fix all this i like your approach that
this is sort of an ongoing issue and
that we need a cabinet level
department of the attention economy to
uh to deal with these problems
well let's dig into the tool kit a
little bit more because i'm already
learning a ton from you
um so i i love seeing it as
something of a negative externality like
attention beyond a certain point where
you say look
like i was thinking beyond our ex
um is probably not a great thing for you
i love your saying look
between midnight and six am probably
terrible for
for teenagers to be uh facebooking it up
or
or whatnot like uh what uh just throw a
few things out there
like that also belong somewhere in like
the consideration center toolkit
yeah you know we're gonna be publishing
um some more on this on our website
soon i have some of it up here right now
but i think a more comprehensive
approach
is something like what we had for the
financial crisis where we had
a comprehensively risk creating system
and we needed comprehensive basel iii
reforms in europe or the dodd-frank kind
of reforms the united states
i know there's some problems with that
but that's thematically what we would
want to be going after
so we need protection for kids privacy
for people transparency for platforms
you can imagine
you get section 230 protections for
content but not for
amplification or recommendation systems
and in exchange for getting section 230
protections for those who don't know
it's what prevents is what enables
platforms to not be liable for bad
content on their platforms
but in exchange for that there has to be
transparency to the public and to many
civil society groups
to be able to say which things we want
to measure about the use or
or prevalence of certain kinds of
content
so that we can actually do a better job
of regulating them because we don't even
have transparency now about
how bad is the teenage mental health
problem how many users beneath the age
of 16
are using it between two and four in the
morning if we had transparency we could
actually
make them report not to a board of
directors but to a board of the people
based on these metrics that matter to us
in a democratically governed society
oh that is enormous so modifying section
230 in those ways would be
huge because in many ways that is
these companies licensed to uh
operate and print money really that's
right you know
and this was written in 96 before any of
these companies even existed like we
couldn't
really anticipated youtube and facebook
and tick tock you know many years later
uh yeah so we need to examine
this license essentially and what you're
suggesting is a difference between
posting content and then spreading
advertising content or
uh messages or videos that there's some
kind of commercial incentive attached to
um so that's a very that's a very
interesting distinction
um the other interesting thing you're
attaching to it is to say look
we're gonna give you this and in some
cases this franchise is worth you know
billions even trillions of dollars but
in return we get data
they get real data about what the actual
public harms are
um because if you compare this to a
negative externality where you look at
you know for example with pollution you
look around and say okay there's a
you know there are negative effects
through climate change and this one we
actually need the data the social media
companies have in order to measure
um a lot of the harms that's right and
so this is table stakes this is not the
thing that answers the problems this is
the sort of prerequisite for being able
to do anything a metaphor i often have
anderson so using these
climate change analogies is it's like
facebook is like exxon
but they're the exon of human anxiety
except they also don't just own
the kind of you know extraction of oil
they also own the
entire satellite network that we have to
observe and measure how much co2
so they actually control the measurement
of how bad the problem is
so this is ridiculous it's almost like
it's you know if you take the monopoly
conversation it's a vertically
integrated company that owns both the
measurement
you know either the exclusive access to
measurement of the harm
and also the harm creation that's a
vertically integrated perverse
sort of company there's also other
aspects freedom from manipulation
accountability for harms enabling more
competition and we can
to dig into that because it's less about
as you said magically breaking them up
causes the removal of misinformation or
addiction in society because you still
have a race to the bottom to create
those problems um and then also national
security because we haven't talked about
that
that you know while we've been obsessed
you know by some
uh folks and politicians of protecting
our physical borders
we've been leaving our digital borders
wide open and this is really important
because if russia or china tried to fly
a plane into the physical united states
where they try to get across the
passport controls we have
huge billions of dollars invested in
either shooting down that plane or
stopping them at the border but it's
still none of us would accept it
none of us would accept the fact that
you have you have 70 countries
right now that are uh investing in
misinformation and everyone's like oh
you know if you had 70 countries flying
planes through our airspace we'd all be
like what the heck is going on that's
exactly right and so and
so if you think about it as how much of
the surface area of our
of our country's activities happens in
the physical world
and how much of that surface area is
moving into the virtual world
of kind of facebook instagram clicks
advertising email etc
and more and more of our economic
activity is moving from the physical to
the digital but we don't protect the
digital borders
so if russia and china try to fly an
information plane
into the virtual united states instead
of being met by the pentagon to shoot it
down they're met by a facebook algorithm
with a white glove that says yeah
exactly which zip code
or minority group would you like to
target with more divisive information
that could stir up culture wars
so this is a urgent national security
threat that we've been meaning to try to
get
you know more into the agenda because i
think we don't we massively
underestimate the vulnerability of
culture
you know after world war ii you know big
powers like russia
china iran turkey they're not going to
um you know
attack the united states with nuclear
weapons anymore they can't do kinetic
warfare
and so what would you do you would
actually want to take the divisions in a
country that already exist
walk over their virtual borders and stir
up culture wars and racial divides
everywhere
which is exactly what we're seeing them
doing we also know that russia has gone
after
ex-us veteran groups and trying to sow
more discontent about
you know uh uh they're not so dark we
know that they're
we know that russia is going after
environmentalist groups um in fact
they actually go after
pro-environmentalists anti-fracking u.s
advocates like greenpeace and mag and
amplify them because what happens if in
the us we don't frac
we have to buy more foreign oil from
where from russia
so there's many different aspects to
this problem but i think what people
need to know
is that this is in all of our interests
it's not a partisan issue
um it's really a a global issue and a
national security issue
that affects everyone oh tristan you're
a blessing to us all the fact that
you've been fighting this fight
in sometimes in relative pain and
obscurity
uh and now this is a moment when
everyone can look at you and say
he's been onto something this whole time
just like your old colleagues at google
who were like hey i didn't see it but
now i see it
we all see it now which is the first big
step towards solving a problem is
acknowledging its existence and now we
have to solve it as quickly as possible
because time is not on our side and this
stuff's getting nastier
more virulent it's going to make it
impossible for us to
this is the problem that if you don't
solve it you can't solve anything else
that's right but i do think the thing
that gives me hope andrew
is that you know what's what's been
missing is the collective will of the
people and public pressure
and i wish i could show the world my
inbox because
i didn't even have an instagram account
that i hadn't used since 2000 2012.
and now suddenly i went from you know no
followers or whatever to something like
50 000 i get messages from all around
the world from people saying
i'm ready to i'm ready to do everything
i can this is too important everyone
wants to solve this problem so i
probably feel like you did
where you're just getting messages from
people around the country saying we got
to solve it and i know that's not enough
we have to actually translate it into
meaningful action and political energy
but i think that the difference between
this and climate change is unlike seeing
the movie inconvenient truth
and then saying well this is going to
happen to my grandkids if this is the
climate change of culture and it's sort
of a disaster for our social fabric
after seeing the movie you turn to that
glass slab in your pocket
and you stare at it 80 more times that
day and you know that it's causing these
problems
so i think that this really is the issue
we can all unite around and that gives
me
an incredible hope and i think as you
said you know awareness precedes the
opportunity for choice
i think the question everyone can ask
themselves is instead of my attention
being the commodity we can also ask
what what is worth our attention
individually and also what is worth our
attention
as a as a country um because i think the
current attention economy does not
reflect you know what really matters to
us
none of us would choose this that's for
sure tristan and we're going to have to
actually
decide what to choose if we give
ourselves that chance
so so pumped to reconnect with you
congratulations
on on your organization and movement
and documentary getting to this point
and i'm thrilled to work with you
because we got to solve these problems i
you know one thing
i i i do get those messages and i
appreciate the yangyang and the love so
much
i you know we should maybe give a name
for your gang um
humans whatever it is um but but the the
challenge
now uh just to give you like uh uh you
know like at least my sense of things
is what you just said is like look
you're the people then you have this
political energy and then you have a
political system that is not exactly
super high functioning
that's the thing and then you have in
this case in your case
you have these 650 billion dollar
companies or you know multi-billion
dollar companies
who are like the biggest richest they're
like almost countries unto themselves
uh and and when they look up and see our
national government they do not think to
themselves like oh
like um you know these people uh know
what's best for me and my business
like i should really listen to them
[Laughter]
it's more like so so this is like the
popular energy is an enormous
first step but activating our political
machinery to actually
like make these changes and bring some
of these companies to the table
um popular zeal will help because a lot
of the folks work at these companies
like you did
a lot of the folks obviously you know
like have kids themselves or use the
services
um but yeah like the the real fight is
coming
yeah well you know i i uh i think we
have actually a lot of lessons to learn
from
probably people who used to formally
work for you because we do need to build
a movement on the back
of i think what the film is creating um
i think there's so much energy to change
but
uh we we have to channel it in
appropriate directions and i know
there's some things coming up locally in
california the consumer privacy act um
consumer privacy reform
rights excuse me um and some you know
more action in europe
uh but i i want to encourage people to
really get involved um
to you know educate yourself we do have
more resources on on humanetech.com
uh but honestly andrew i'd love to learn
more as well about how do we activate a
movement around this because
it is how we see it i think we have to
organize a constituency that this is the
issue that's beneath other issues
well you and i are going to connect i'm
going to text you
and i want to be a resource to you in
any way i can uh
um if someone does want to get
uh energized around your movement is it
is humanetech.com the best place to go
yeah um the best place to go is
humanetech.com
for those who want to know just how they
take control of the
things and the effects that they saw in
the film there's a take control page
we also have a great podcast called your
undivided attention where we interview
many of the people who are in the film
the social dilemma
but go in depth on you know youtube
recommendations go in depth on russian
disinformation go in depth on
the casino-like slot machine design of
social media
and that's a good place to educate
yourself and we're really working now on
on kind of mobilization so how do we
build those catchment systems
that mobilize people and i would frankly
andrew i would really love to follow up
with you about
um how you did that and who we could
leverage from your movement to help us
because i think
this i think we can really get a large
constituency that's also bipartisan too
done and done we are at your disposal
let's give it up for tristan harris
tristan thank you so much brother please
it's such a pleasure to be here andrea i
really really appreciate what you've
done and
um i i'm really excited to follow up i
really think this is so important so
thank you so much for having me too
[Music]
you